حلقه صغيره وضيقه شكلها الى ماسك لاداره
منصته الزرقاء تويتر والحلقه تضم اصدقاء
ومستثمرون ومحامون مقربون لماسك سيكونون
ضمن الفريق الجديد الذي سيدير شركه تويتر
في المرحله المقبله والهدف الاستمراريه
وزياده الارادات حيث سيضم المجلس الجديد
الذي يساعد ماسك في اجراءات تقييم الشركه
وتنزيل رؤيته ومشاريعه محاميه الشخصيه
ومستثمرين من اصدقائه ومدير تنفيذه سابق
في تويتر ترك الشركه قبل سنوات الاختيار
الاول كان على الشريك القديم
والمستثمر في مجال التكنولوجيا جيسون الذي
طرح العديد من الافكار حول مستقبل الشركه
وعين في منصب مهندس برمجيات داخل الشركه
اما جارد الذي يعد اقرب مستشاري الى ماسك
يدير ثروته الشخصيه كرئيس لمكتب عائلتي
منذ العام 2016 وكان من المساهمين
الرئيسيين في اعداد تمويل صفقه شراء تويتر
فسيكون احد واضح خطط واستراتيجيات عمل
تويتر في المرحله المقبله المحامي اليكس
بيرو فلقد تحول من الممثل القانوني له
ماسك الى المسؤول عن الفرق القانونيه
والعلاقات الحكوميه والسياسيه والتسويق في
تويتر وديفيد ثانكس الذي عمل مع ماسك منذ
ان كان لاثنان جزءا من فريق شركه بايبال
قبل 20 سنه فسيتولى منصب مهندس برامج
الموظفين اما القيادي سيرام كريشنا انه
سيساعد مع ماسك في اداره المنصه مؤقتا
واشارت واشنطن مهامه في تويتر غير واضحه
لكنه يبقى الوحيد في فريق مارس الذي سبق
له العمل في هذه الشركه
[موسيقى]